today's video is brought to you by
innovative language the creators of
finished pod 101 click the link in the
description to check out their huge
collection of audio and video lessons
for students of all levels hello
everyone
welcome to the Lang focused channel and
my name is Paul today we're going to
compare two languages that are closely
related to each other and similar in
many ways but also quite different from
each other with limited mutual
intelligibility I'm talking about two
non-indo-european languages of northern
Europe Finnish and Estonian Finnish and
Estonian are both members of the finnick
group of languages along with karelian
ludecke vets ingrian voting and livonian
their most recent common ancestor
language was late proto Finnick around
2,000 years ago
Finnick is a branch of the Uralic
language family so they are both more
distantly related to Hungarian as well
since Finnish and Estonian have been
developing in different directions for
2000 years they are now fairly different
with Estonian being much more innovative
while Finnish is more conservative in
other words Estonian has changed more
they're not mutually intelligible for
the most part aside from basic general
vocabulary Estonian speakers generally
understand Finnish better than Finnish
speakers understand Estonian because of
exposure to Finnish media though I
understand that this is much less the
case among the young generations today
let's look at a few common phrases in
either language and see what's similar
and what's different about them hello in
Finnish Hey and in Estonian data or data
Beast this word literally means health
the T here is a positive case inflection
positive is the case used for direct
objects when they are partial objects
rather than complete ones data is a
contraction of data beast but Finnish
also has the formal word Bhairava for
hello which literally means healthy this
is a cognate with the Estonian word data
Beast except Televi is an adjective
rather than a noun in Estonian data is
used with many greetings well in Finnish
Hoover is used Estonian has a cognate of
this word yeah they both mean good good
morning in Finnish River aha moment on
this noun is in the positive case and is
a literary word from morning in Finnish
in Estonian den a home in coast here you
can see that these two words are
cognates and both come from proto
Finnick home end but the Estonian word
is in the elated case which is used with
the sense of from or out of a good day
or good afternoon in Finnish river by
Eva and in Estonian data Baathist again
here you can see that these two words
are cognates these cognates reveal an
important difference between Finnish and
Estonian Finnish uses vowel harmony
while Estonian no longer uses vowel
harmony except in some archaic
expressions in Finnish there are three
classes of vowels front vowels neutral
vowels and back vowels if a word
contains front vowels it cannot contain
back vowels and vice versa this also
applies to the word suffixes by Eva this
is a front vowel so aside from this
neutral vowel the other vowel is also a
front vowel ballast here we see a front
vowel and a neutral vowel but there's a
back vowel in the suffix this word
doesn't exhibit the same vowel harmony
as the finnish word but it's worth
noting that vowel harmony may be seen in
southern Estonian dialects good evening
in Finnish here the elta and in Estonian
deado just in this case these phrases
contain no cognate words what's your
name in Finnish make a synonym easy own
word-for-word what your name is semen is
the genitive inflection of the personal
pronoun Sina semen also has a short form
that is used in informal speech soon me
Kazumi my own in Estonian Missy no enemy
and just like in Finnish Estonian also
has a short form of the genitive pronoun
missiny me and whether we use the long
forms or the short forms you can see
that the finnish and estonian sentences
are pretty close to each other one
difference is the word for what another
difference is
the form of the word for name in finish
the basic nominative form is nimi like
in Estonian but in finished there are
special possessive forms of the
nominative when there's a genitive
pronoun to show possession a
corresponding possessive suffix is added
to the end of the noun and in this case
it changes the final vowel though that
doesn't always happen the full suffix C
is used in formal written finish while a
shortened suffix is usually used in
spoken finish or the suffix is dropped
becasue Nemean when the suffix is
dropped it's more like the Estonian
sentence possessive suffix has
disappeared from estonian in the 17th
century so whereas in finnish you can
say a possessive sentence without the
genitive personal pronoun in estonian
you need it for example in the sentences
meaning my name is in Finnish Nia and I
own here there's no genitive pronoun but
there's a possessive suffix in Estonian
minou anemia and here there's a genitive
pronoun but there's no possessive suffix
false friends so far we've seen that
some words are different in other words
are cognates while those cognates often
have different forms or different
inflectional forms but as with most
languages that are closely related to
each other
there are also some false friends
cognates that look and sound similar but
actually have different meanings for
example in Finnish Gori star means to
decorate the Estonian word chorus Thema
means to clean the core meaning of these
words is to make beautiful so you can
see how that developed into both of
their present meanings in Finnish Maya
means a shelter or a tree house and in
Estonian Maya is the regular word for
house the Finnish word horn means a room
the Estonian word hona means a big
building the Finnish word it means a
cabin but a cabin on a boat
the Estonian word he means a hut or a
shack both of these words are Germanic
long words the Finnish one from Swedish
and the Estonian one from old High
German the Finnish word Rama means Bible
the Estonian word
means book the word for book and finish
is kiria
and the word for bible in estonian is ve
been finnish is much more conservative
in its vocabulary meaning that there
have been strong efforts to use Finnish
words or coin new words from Finnish
roots instead of adopting lone words for
modern objects and concepts for example
in Estonian the word for telephone is
they'll have fun Finnish had the word
telephony but replaced it with for
hailing Estonian contains many long
words especially from middle low German
and German Finnish sticks to its Finnish
roots for most of these the word for
kitchen in Finnish gate dear and in
Estonian good the Finnish word was
coined in the 19th century from the word
meaning to cook plus a suffix that forms
nouns from verbs the Estonian word comes
from middle low German where Finnish
does use long words they're often from
Swedish as we saw in a previous pair of
false friends another example is the
words for doctor in Finnish lagari which
comes from Swedish and in Estonian
artist which comes from middle low
German grammar
Finnish and Estonian have many
grammatical features in common both
Finnish and Estonian are synthetic
languages that means that meaning can be
added to a sentence by adding additional
morphemes to a word rather than adding
additional words both have a combination
of agglutinating and fusional elements
though Estonian has become somewhat less
synthetic with the loss of some
inflectional affixes like the loss of
the possessive suffixes we saw before
another example is that Estonian verbs
in their negative conjugation have no
affixes showing person making subject
pronouns necessary unlike in Finnish
neither language has grammatical gender
there are no masculine feminine neuter
distinctions neither language has
articles like that or in English for
example in Finnish Paulo means either
the house or a house and also in
Estonian Maya means either the house or
a house both Finnish and Estonian have
both prepositions and postpositions
neither language has a separate future
temps the simple present is also used
for the future for example these
sentences can mean either I study
English or I will study English in
Finnish OPA scale in England dia and in
Estonian map in English again
but the Estonian sentence actually needs
some more context in order to be
interpreted as future tense if you add
an adverb of time like tomorrow then
we'll know it's future tense rather than
present tense home opening difficult
without that context the word Hakan
could be used to indicate the future it
literally means start but is used like
going to in English Moroccan English
again Bheema
Finnish and Estonian have similar case
systems Finnish has 15 cases while
Estonian has 14 though there are two
others that are sometimes included as
well
there's no accusative case on the
Estonian list but as in Finnish the
accusative form is the same as either
the nominative or the genitive form
grammatical differences the inflections
are different between the languages of
course we saw some examples of that
before in verb conjugations and in case
inflections Estonian syntax has some
influence from low German and German
for example Estonian often uses
postpositions
whereas in Finnish a case would be used
for example the phrase meaning on the
table in Finnish bird Allah and in
Estonian lower Bell the Finnish noun is
in the Edessa of case which gives the
meaning of on or at in Estonian there's
a separate word a post position meaning
on in Finnish subject pronouns are
normally left out for the first and
second person except for emphasis
but the third person is required that's
in the written formal language in casual
speech the pronouns are normally used
though not always in Estonian they're
more often left out in casual speech for
example these sentences mean I read a
book first informal Finnish Mina Lewin
quirian and an informal Finnish mallow
in Korean and in Estonian with the
pronoun malukas Andromeda Libby and
without the pronoun look i syndromic de
la vie while in finnish the use of the
pronoun depends more on the register
with the pronoun normally dropped in
formal written Finnish but included in
spoken Finnish in Estonian the use of
the pronoun doesn't really depend on the
register it's normal to either use or
drop the pronoun in both formal written
and spoken Estonian one other difference
here is that an Estonian the word Lobby
is necessary because the object here is
a whole object like the accusative case
it adds the meaning of through like I
read through the whole book this word
would be unnecessary if the noun was in
the positive case referring to only part
of the book
next we're going to simply dive into
some sentences and see what we find
these sentences mean
I study literature in university in
Finnish Maori skanky really suit the
earlier pistols I I study literature in
University and in Estonian open equally
skiddy underst word for word it's I
study in university literature first
notice that the finished sentence
contains a subject pronoun while the
Estonian sentence doesn't remember that
in either language people can use or
drop the pronoun but in speech it's
normally used in Finnish while it's more
often dropped in spoken Estonian next we
see a pair of cognates meaning study or
peace killin not bin
there's an interesting difference here
the Finnish verb has a suffix that makes
it frequent ative meaning it shows a
repeated action it changes the meaning
of the verb from learn to study but if
we remove the suffix it's a lot more
like the Estonian word open the Estonian
word can be used as it is with the
meaning of study even though it also
means learn next the words for
literature are cognates both are in the
positive case the case used for partial
direct objects in this case the person
doesn't study literature and all its
entirety that would be impossible the
person studies only part of the
literature available so the partitive
case is used but obviously even though
the same case is used in both languages
the inflectional forms are rather
different next the words for university
are different though both are in the
Anessa case which adds the meaning of in
note that the inflection of the finnish
word is an abbreviated colloquial form
it matches the informality of the
sentence shown by the short pronoun and
one more sentence if you drove more
slowly I would be able to read the map
in Finnish yes is it he Tom in me in
posters in Luke M Encarta word-for-word
it's if you would drive more slowly then
I would be able to read map and in
Estonian quiz arguments reduxid Saxon
guard delicata word-for-word it's if you
more slowly you would drive I would be
able to map read first we see different
words meaning if here Finnish has no
pronoun which tell
this is likely more formal Finnish in
Estonian the pronoun is present which is
common in both formal and informal
registers next we see two different
verbs meaning drive but both are in the
second person singular conditional I'm
sure you notice the difference in word
order this is interesting because in
Estonian the verb comes at the end of
the if clause
this likely shows the influence of low
German or old high german in german and
low german the conjugated verb comes at
the end of subordinate clauses of which
if clauses are one type if we skip ahead
to the second part of this sentence the
main clause we also see word order that
looks Germanic the auxiliary verb is at
the beginning and the lexical verb comes
at the end of the clause the auxiliary
verb is not in second position as in
German or low German because the subject
pronoun is dropped here but we did see
that word order before in the sentence
maja can English again Bheema here the
conjugated verb is in the second
position and the second verb comes at
the end as in German or low German next
we see two different comparative adverbs
meaning more slowly in Finnish adverbs
are formed by adding T to the inflecting
form of the adjective then to form the
comparative adverb ste is replaced by
min in Estonian the stem of adverbs is
the genitive singular form of the
adjective to that we add the suffix LT
then to make the adverb comparative you
remove that ending and add mult
next in the finished sentence we see
ninh meaning then to show the outcome of
a condition but in Estonian it's not
used there is a word that can be used
cease which serves the same function but
the sentence is fine without it
in Finnish it's better to include the
word mean and the sentence would sound a
bit strange without it next we see two
different verbs meaning I would be able
to both are in the first person singular
conditional mood next we have two
cognate verbs meaning to read but these
two verbs reveal a grammatical
difference between Finnish and Estonian
the finnish verb is a third active
infinitive in the elated case finnish
has five different infinitive forms and
this one is used in verb chains like
this estonian has only two types of
infinitive the my infinite
and the dye infinitive this one is the
dye infinitive the dye infinitive is
used when something may or may not
actually occur whereas the ma infinitive
is used for things that are certain the
DA infinitive is used in sentences
meaning things like she can or he may or
we want etc because the action is not
certain and after that we have cognate
words for map both in the positive case
but with different inflectional forms as
you can see Finnish and Estonian
function very similarly and their shared
roots are obvious but it's also obvious
that they split off from each other a
very long time ago Estonian is by far
the more innovative language and readily
open to changes while Finnish is much
more conservative at least standard
Finnish if we introduced Finnish
dialects into the comparison there might
be more similarities with Estonian
standard Estonian was based more on
northern Estonian dialects as they were
spoken
whereas standard Finnish was based more
on conservative forms that were common
to all or most Finnish dialects the
question of the day for speakers of
Finnish and Estonian how well do you
understand the other language do you
think exposure to the other language
would be enough to get used to it and
understand it for other people what's
your impression of these two languages
how similar do they seem to you if
you're interested in learning Finnish
I recommend you click the link in the
description to check out Finnish pod 101
they have hundreds of audio and video
lessons with full transcripts for
students of all levels sign up for a
free account and give it a try special
thanks to my patreon supporters
especially these wonderful people right
here on the screen they are the top tier
patreon supporters of this channel so
many extra special thanks to them and to
everyone thank you for watching and have
a nice day